c'est exactement ce que les gens commencent
à dire qu'il n'y aura plus d'
avortements dans l'état du
mississippi c'est un tas de conneries
conneries tu détestes le savoir tu détestes le
savoir les
gens vont essayer de s'auto-
avorter les gens vont mourir
tu ne montres aucune pitié
en tuant votre
enfant par commodité s'il est assassiné
appelé dieu vous êtes déjà une mère la
bible dit que tu ne le tueras pas dit également qu'il
y aura des options
dans le mississippi pour se faire avorter
ils ne seront tout simplement pas bons
l'organisation pour la santé des femmes jackson
était au centre de l'affaire dobbs contre
jackson que la cour suprême a utilisée
pour annuler roe v wade pendant des années maintenant,
c'est la seule clinique d'avortement dans l'
état du mississippi et au moment où vous
verrez ce film, elle sera fermée
pour  brute, je rencontre ren allen,
un défenseur bénévole de la clinique qui aide les
patients à traverser la foule d'
anti-avortement afin qu'ils puissent
accéder à la clinique dans ses derniers jours
[Rires]
nous conduisons  g jusqu'à la clinique il est euh 4
h 45 du matin
nous avons de sérieuses craintes que les
antis ne bloquent l'
allée ce matin pour empêcher
nos patients d'avoir accès aux soins de santé il
n'y a jamais eu de flics avec eux d'
accord
quand je vous dis que je  Je n'ai jamais vu de
flic ici,
je pense que c'est ce qu'ils veulent dire quand ils
disent qu'elle va les enhardir,
nous avons des heures avant même que les patients ne commencent à se
présenter, c'est comme ça que vous savez que cette merde
n'a rien à voir
avec l'accès réel aux soins de santé pour lesquels
je me porte volontaire  accompagner les gens de leur
voiture à la porte afin qu'ils puissent avoir accès
aux soins de santé dont ils ont besoin
rin était le dernier volontaire à bord de
la maison rose car une fois que la
décision de la cour suprême sur la girafe a été divulguée,
ils savaient que la clinique devrait fermer
même si elle n'a pas pu le faire longtemps,
elle a dit qu'elle voulait aider
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment aimeriez-vous votre petit bébé aimer
votre bébé dans l'utérus comme vous aimez ce
bébé sur vos genoux d'
accord, nous allons laisser  tu  ramassez-la bien,
vous pouvez sauvegarder pour moi pendant une
seconde merci merci vous pouvez
remonter votre fenêtre maintenant ma chérie
oui en
gardant les antis hors de la propriété
ils aiment trouver cette ligne
et la pousser
pour qu'ils se tiennent dans l'allée  ils
bloqueront les voitures essayant d'entrer ils
grimperont les échelles avec leurs
pancartes et leurs klaxons et leur
haine et ils crieront et filmeront par-
dessus la clôture ils filmeront les patients
ils crieront sur les patients
et ce n'est pas nouveau
ils ont  cela fait des années et
c'est définitivement illégal et personne ne s'en soucie,
Dieu vous appelle à comparaître aujourd'hui,
nous restons là et nous subissons les abus et
nous les distrayons et nous dansons et nous
rions et nous crions
et pendant que tout ce qui se passe, les patients
ont accès  aux soins de santé juste
derrière nous
j'ai été élevé conservateur j'ai été élevé
républicain
j'ai été élevé en regardant Bill O'reilly
aux nouvelles le matin en mangeant des céréales en
me préparant pour l'
école
[Applaudissements]
une fois que j'ai commencé à devenir ami avec
peo  ple qui ne me ressemblait pas et
ne pensait pas comme moi et venait d'
horizons différents du
mien
mon opinion a commencé à changer radicalement
il arrive un moment où vous pouvez prendre
vos propres décisions et faire vos propres
recherches
[Musique]
parfois ils  arrêtez-les au coin de la rue
et
hier, ils ont commencé à dire aux gens que
la clinique était fermée et que nous avions
peut-être deux voitures
qui sont restées et qui n'ont pas fini par
monter dans la rue, alors
oh mon dieu,
je ne peux pas,
c'est de la folie sur laquelle
nous nous disputons  une place de parking
c'est ce qu'ils font je ne te touche pas
je ne te touche pas je ne te touche
pas je ne te touche pas c'est comme si
tu faisais tout mais
et puis c'est
toi qui a des ennuis pour
réagissent
à une situation et ils n'ont jamais d'
ennuis à cause de cela
ils ne le font jamais
et vous ne pouvez pas réagir
parce que vous obtenez une réaction et vous êtes une
femme irrationnelle vous obtenez une réaction et
vous n'êtes plus valide l'
avortement est illégal l'
avortement est illégal  dans le mississippi
pas d'avortement n'est pas il  légal dans l'état
du mississippi mais nous avons 10 jours pour que
cette clinique soit ouverte ils peuvent se faire
avorter pendant 10 jours ils mentent
ils mentent aux patients
et leur disent de se détourner après l'annulation de
roe v wade le
procureur général du mississippi a dû  certifier la
loi de déclenchement interdisant les avortements dans le
mississippi cela a donné à la maison rose dix
jours de plus pour fonctionner
diable l'autre personne qui t'écoute
est le diable parce qu'il se
moque d'un bébé est assassiné oh tu tire
la langue du bébé gros meurtre
c'est encore mieux
je me suis dit je n'allais pas leur parler
quelque chose qui m'a vraiment frappé comme  étrange
quand j'ai commencé à faire du bénévolat
ici, c'était comme la production
de pièces de théâtre de tout et comment les défenseurs choisissent
d'engager certaines personnes, vous savez
qu'ils essaieront de débattre avec les antis
qu'ils essaieront de co  nvince que les
autres leur crieront dessus en réponse
quand ils nous crieront dessus
moi personnellement je
souris juste rire danser se
moquer d'eux ils sont assis ici et
ils parlent si calmement
de retirer les droits de quelqu'un en matière de soins de
santé vous savez et ça souffle  mon
esprit qu'ils s'attendent à ce que vous puissiez
avoir des débats rationnels entre guillemets vous
savez sur le droit de quelqu'un à l'
avortement c'est incroyablement difficile de
garder votre sang-froid au moins pour moi parce
que je tiens tellement à vous que nous vous apprécions
merci beaucoup ouais bien sûr
merci beaucoup tout l'amour fille tout
l'amour
ne lui parle pas mec elle
ne veut clairement pas te parler
laisse ça
que penses-tu que le cœur de dieu est une
jeune femme ce petit bébé est un cadeau
de dieu que veux-tu  je pense que le cœur du seigneur
est de l'amener ici et de le
tuer
dieu qui dit que tu le
feras  même s'ils
enfreignent, vous ne leur dites pas un mot
et c'est l'une des choses que notre propriétaire
nous a dit quand elle a dit que nous pouvions engager
ce sont nos [ __ ] de trottoirs et nous
les récupérons, vous n'êtes pas censé
toucher la propriété privée  ta maman
ne t'a-t-elle jamais appris qu'elle m'a appris à ne
pas assassiner des bébés et toi mon grand
ouais as-tu assassiné des enfants innocents
comment as-tu grand garçon non elle ne t'a pas appris
à ne pas être
impoli c'est un engagement grossier peut être aussi peu
que dynamitage  la musique quand ils
font ça ça peut faire du
bruit
ça peut être une interaction en tête-à-tête
et
on fait n'importe quoi mais pendant qu'on fait
ça on garde aussi les patients à l'esprit
qu'ils passent en premier ce qui est cool c'est
la vie
nous aimons notre voisin tu es un voisin
tant que ce précieux bébé
aimerais-tu ce petit bébé aujourd'hui
ne tue pas ton propre enfant aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est juste que
c'est très intimidant et effrayant
pour les patients, en particulier les patients plus jeunes
qui conduisent ici seuls
et  tous les obstacles  Ils ont déjà
sauté juste pour pouvoir obtenir des
soins d'avortement,
puis ils doivent passer devant tout cela
ces gens sur le trottoir ils sont
bien organisés
extrêmement bien
financés ils gagnent
depuis que je vous ai dit de prendre le petit déjeuner pour
les trolls
nous  j'ai quelques jours de plus
huit jours
nous pouvons passer par les six
vasectomies ce serait bien je suis sûr que sa
femme l'apprécierait
je ne pense pas que ça ait l'air bien mais
nous ferons ce que nous pourrons merci beaucoup
nous l'apprécions merci  vous tellement
vous êtes les bienvenus passez une bonne journée à faire un
don
depuis des années maintenant l'avortement n'est ni
super accessible
ni une option légitime pour beaucoup de
gens de la classe ouvrière
et maintenant cela
va juste être exacerbé
c'est trop réel si je pense à la façon dont  cela
m'affecte personnellement
parce qu'alors je dois penser à
vous savez tout ce qu'on m'a jamais enseigné
sur la
justice et la
liberté et la démocratie
ne s'applique pas à moi,
ce sont juste des gens qui se promènent à l'
extérieur qui ne pensent pas que vous êtes un
plein  hum  un être
qui mérite une
pleine autonomie corporelle
et puis il suffit d'aller à l'
épicerie et de leur sourire et de leur
faire signe ou de leur faire boire un verre au bar
ou de rire de leurs petites blagues stupides lors
des dîners de famille
et tout le temps qu'ils
sont juste assis  là
pensant oh ouais
elle ne devrait pas décider de ce qui arrive
à son
corps et je ne sais pas quoi faire avec
ça
j'ai grandi ici
celle-ci était morte oh c'est tellement intelligent que
nous avons des noirs au lieu de blancs
t-
flips c'est tellement excitant c'est tellement excitant
prêt rock and roll
j'ai écouté la chanson en
boucle
[Musique]
pouvez-vous m'entendre je suis un professeur de théâtre
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que cela radicalisera les gens
parce que je ne suis pas désespéré en ce moment et
je ne suis certainement pas impuissant
[Applaudissements]
je vais continuer à me battre nous le sommes tous
il y avait un monde avant
ça et il y aura un monde après ça
je suis sacrément sûr de me battre pour ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi